hello everyone and welcome to a great
game from round seven of the Lin Doris a
B rapid challenge it's published number
one young Christopher doodle versus vs.
world champion magnus carlsen and like I
said it's it's quite the game so let's
just dive straight into it so Duda opens
with c4 he goes for the English opening
and E 5 by Magnus with Knight to c3
Knight f6 Knight to f3 and Knight to c6
the four Knights of the English
basically what everyone place today
we've seen the game the video before
this one Nakamura vs Eric Eric and he
went for the names of each variation
preventing blacks early strike with the
D with d5 but here do that was for e3 so
the the so called quiet line we have
Bishop to b4 by Magnus going for very
rapid development preparing the castle
and Queen to c2 now if the knight is
captured you can recapture with the
Queen and also you keep an eye on the e4
square so Magnus castles in the Knights
to d5 now attacking the the bishop here
but Magnus not worried about it just
rook e8 continues development he's not a
he's not worried about a knight capture
son before as it is okay to give up the
bishop prepare in this variation so
Quinta f5 by Duda this is the the
popular way this line is played
practically inviting d6 to open up a
discovery here on the Queen but that's
you know that's that's why this line is
played so d6 we have Knight captures on
f6 with check and now you could capture
with the Queen there are a lot of games
of the database where Queen captures on
f6 was played but the real party starts
after G captures an f6 which is what
Magnus plays he wants his pawn structure
in front of the king but he gets
excellent center and he might he might
be able to use the G file for his own
attack so Queen to h5 now preparing
Bishop to d3 to go after the h7 pawn and
the Magna strikes in the center with d5
now if there should be three he will
have support for efore but this is
exactly how this line goes with a3
attacking the bishop bishop back to the
fate that the bishop on f8 will be very
useful in defending the black king and
now Bishop to d3 just threatening Queen
captures on h7 checkmate which seems
like it runs into efore which winds the
winds the piece for a while but it's not
a problem since you will eliminate the
d5 pawn so Magnus goes e4 he prevents
checkmate but now C capture Sun d5 now
attacking the knight here the pawn is
nicely defended by the Queen so he
captures on d3 and now de captures and
c6 we have B captures on c6 and now
before procuring to bring the bishop
into the attack
we have Bishop to b2 so a 5 immediately
getting
attacking that b4 pawn wanting to open
up b DD a file for the rook and now
Bishop to b2 so the bishop is nicely
developed and here the position has
already been been reached in 1993 in a
game between you la hora Watt and
Matthew Sadler and Matthew Sadler is act
as the co-author of the game changer the
book on alpha 0 if you don't know so
it's no wonder that he would have such a
such a crazy position and in that game
as Sadler played a capture Sun before
but here Magnus goes for rook to e4
instead puts more pressure on the b4
pawn
also it's just very nice to have your
work on e4 you can also use it for
defense with row G for regards the G
file also you can attack so it's a
multi-purpose move and it's also a new
move in the position so already as of
move 15 we have a completely new game so
Duda continues with Knight to d4 puts
pressure on the c6 pawn and here Magnus
can do a lot of different things he can
go a capture some b4 rook the g4 is an
idea going after the g2 pawn but instead
he decides to defend the c6 bone by
Queen to d5 now defending the pawn while
also attacking the White Queen and here
do that without much much consideration
trades the Queen's we have Queen
captures on d5 captures on d5 and now f3
which not only kicks away the rook but
also takes care of the g4 square so rook
to e8 and now here is a where Duda
really took it took his time at the
decide what to do whether to go b5 which
will put a lot of pressure on black
position it's not not at all clear how
black will develop his pieces as both
the dark square and light square bishop
are pretty much blocked in or night the
b5 which opens up an attack on the f6
pawn but also on the c7 point and this
is what exactly what dude at us he goes
nice to the b5 now threatens Knight to
c7 which would for be the rooks so rook
the e7 by Magnus you have to give up the
doubled f6 pawn with Bishop captures and
the rook to d7 now
so here Duda is up a pawn and he starts
by improving the position of the King we
have King f2 and Bishop to e6 now
attacking the knight Knight back to d4
and now Bishop to c4 so now both of
these pawns are nicely defended but as
long as your bishop on c4 it's it's
pretty much a pawn and here well you
could go at five immediately it is an
excellent square for the knight black
has to be very careful what he does with
the bishop we don't want to allow any
unnecessary tricks here but there's
always time for that so first Duda
improves with rook H 2 b1 now there are
ideas of just capturing you could also
just put it upon to b5 a lot of
possibilities here so rook the a6 by
Magnus forces the bishop to retreat
Bishop to e5 and now f6 pushing the
bishop further back but do that doesn't
retreat instead he takes this
opportunity to advance the b5 pawn and
now the problem is you cannot trade for
example if Bishop captures a white will
not capture here and allow you to
capture an e5 well do that would just
capture on c7 and now you just traded
pawns and you can also trade bishops but
this is all in favor of white so instead
after be five magnets goes Brooke to b6
and now comes Bishop to f4
now you have to retreat and now a for
not allowing do that to play a four to
add another defender to the b5 point so
g4 by Judah he starts his expansion on
the Kings side and now Bishop to c5 now
with ideas of just capturing on the
fore-end winning the b5 pawn now but in
order to do that you would have to give
up your Bishop pair so do the continues
advancing the points on the Kings side
we have h4 and all like I said you could
go for characters captures which doesn't
mess up White's pawn structure and you
could character here but the Magnus
first decides to improve
position he's not in a rush to win back
the pawn so king f7 and now pink the g3
by Judah and only now he goes for the
capture Bishop characters night we have
eight captures on d4 and now Magnus
doesn't capture with the rook but rather
he captures with the bishop so Bishop
captures on b5 but this gives Duda an
idea rook the B for now now you cannot
move your better let's say day six as
you lose the a for pawn and here Duda is
preparing rook to be one which will put
pressure on the bishop here and now c6
now immediately is the way is the way to
play this however Magnus went for looked
at east 7 to put a rook on the open e
file but now there's a problem rook a to
be won and now you don't have c6 anymore
because if c6 now then just rook
captures here you grab a pawn you create
a past a pawn and of course if Bishop
captures then you just eliminate the
rook and it's just a much better
position for white so instead Bishop to
c4 Magnus has to give up a pawn here
again so rook captures and b6 pawn
captures and rook captures and b6 but ok
it's still bishops of opposite colors
the position is very very much unclear
it's a rapid game both players very long
time
anything can happen so Bishop back to b3
by Magnus he just has to wait there is
no active plan for black here and Bishop
to d6 now attacks the rook we have rook
to d7
now attack putting pressure on the
bishop and f4 now here Magnus decides to
give up another point with f5 which if
Duda captures then he would really mess
up his pawn structure on the King side
and also maybe cousin could bring his
king over to f6 then capture on f5 and
so on again a lot of activity with Ace
King which of course do that not
interested in he goes g5 and now Russia
back to d1 by Magnus point is if let's
say the bishop moves and you get some
roof to f6 check ideas then maybe the f5
point can fall so you want to have the
option of Bishop g4 to just defend this
f5 pawn so Bishop to c5 now Duda is
threatening rook f6 check so King g7 not
allowing this idea to come with check so
you can always block with the bishop and
now King the f2 by Duda going for for
King III we've looked the d8 by Magnus
just waiting to see what to do that will
do and do
look the b7 width check kingi six by
Magnus and now rook to e7 now grabbing
hold of the open e file and it's very
hard to find an active move for black
this King really doesn't have all that
many squares you can only move the rook
so Carlsen does it he moves the rook to
the open B file but now comes looked at
a six with check and here with rook the
g7 the game still continues white being
a lot better of course but like I said
it's a rapid game both players a very
long time who knows what might happen
but here Magnus goes King to h5 and he
pretty much seals the deal here so feel
free to pause the video here and defeat
the world champion well I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the unstoppable mate in
three and when I say in three I actually
mean in two and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's King g3
you prevent the King from reaching the
g4 square of course and then rook to h6
is checkmate I say made into it rather
than mate in three because of course you
can prolong by one move by playing Ruby
six but we're not I hate to mentioning
those ideas so basically it's a mating -
yeah and after King to g3 of course
Magnus calls and resigned the game and
the brilliant victory for young
Christophe Duda who really had a nice
line prepared Magnus knew the line but
then at some point he forgot how how to
continue and then do the just I took
advantage of that
Magnus started spending a lot of time
and in the end it all worked out well
for Polish number one young shift of
Duda so that's the game I do hope you
enjoy that that we're gonna cover some
more games tomorrow before the start of
the knockout phase as we had 12 players
now tomorrow we're only gonna have eight
players as four players will be
eliminated before the knockout phase but
we're gonna cover a few more games
before we check out the standings so
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank below Aleph on the
Frank Truslow and Warren Sampson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
island or a Savi rapid challenge
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of you